[Music]
villains
often times the best part of a movie
can't live with them
can't feed them to a pack of rabid
hyenas usually
villains are the people we love to hate
or fear with the occasional modicum of
empathy
but something's been happening with
villains lately if you found yourself
nodding along to the logic of a
diabolical plot or feeling more
empathetic than usual towards a film's
antagonist
you're not alone today's villains from
killmonger and black panther to screen
slaver and incredibles 2
have become weirdly relatable each
equipped with their own cogent critiques
of the world
people will trade quality for ease every
time
villainy is and always has been a
reflection of the value systems and
fears of the time so how did we get from
this
to this and what does it say about our
past and our world
today what we're going to find out in
this wisecrack edition on the cinematic
history of villainy
and warning there's a ton of spoilers
here for movies both old and new we have
to explore multiple eras and see
how film villains embody the spirit and
anxieties of the times
now a quick disclaimer none of these
trends are absolute
villains can break the mold or jump back
into the past for inspiration but
what we're discussing here are
noticeable trends among some of the most
enduring films of each era we're going
to start our journey from the simple
mustache twirling villain to the complex
philosophizing radical by looking at the
1950s and early
1960s the height of the war that wasn't
hot
in the post-world war ii party in the
suburbs era of american history
describing our world seemed pretty
simple
we were the heroes who saved the world
from the evil nazis
and were now tasked with staving off the
also evil ussr
it was very black and white and so were
our villains
well yeah literally but also
metaphorically movie screens were full
of bad russian people
bad asian people and very bad aliens
what do all these naughty dudes have in
common they're the other
an inherent inexplicable evil that
stoked on destroying america and our
apple pie values
sometimes that other took the form of an
amorphous red for kami blob
or the creature from the black lagoon
other times the other was an alien
hatched in a pod and designed to look
exactly like you as in the invasion of
the body snatchers which some critics
say represented the fear of communist
brainwashing and infiltration
and you're reborn into an untroubled
world
where everyone's the same exactly
what a world also in the 50s the movie
industry went way
back to basics producing a number of
biblical sagas with running times of
four hours or more
these expensive epics proved massively
popular
with three ranking in the top 10 highest
grossing films of the decade
perhaps this was partially because they
so perfectly embodied cold war
propaganda which depicted a face-off
between god-fearing americans and the
godless communists ben hur showed an
aristocratic jew being persecuted by an
evil roman commander
while quovatus pits new christian
converts against the evil emperor
nero and his roman empire the world is
mine
and mine to end and the ten commandments
depicts good old moses staring down the
egyptian emperor ramses
these films all portrayed the noble
judeo-christian taking on a cruel
powerful despot of a non-monotheistic
religion
these villains were representative of
larger groups of bad people who wanted
to cancel baseball tupperware parties
rain has not only been washed as they
say it has been
dry cleaned
[Laughter]
even when villains weren't explicitly
foreign or pagan
they were just anti-american communist
double agents as seen in a flurry of
cold war propaganda films
later spy mania of the 1960s would also
reflect cold war anxiety
with james bond facing off against
various agents of smearsh the imaginary
russian intelligence agency
the cold war in istanbul will not remain
cold very much longer
what all these movies had in common was
an us versus them mentality
with no good commies portrayed as pure
and simply
evil one-dimensional foreign communist
alien blob villains took a back seat in
the late 60s and 70s
as we saw a definitive shift in the
portrayal of villains
it was fitting for a time of major
social turbulence and soul-searching
as the civil rights movement in vietnam
made visible some of the
not-so-perfect aspects of america like
racism and war
this period also saw a startling drop in
public trust of government
a phenomenon that changed movie villains
dramatically as
outrage over the war meant outrage about
nixon's tapes
notably 1970s movies shined a light on
the corrupt social systems that
americans were
increasingly disillusioned with evil
politicians and public officials loomed
large popular political thriller all the
president's men brought the watergate
scandal to the big screen in 1976.
fictional accounts also touched on
institutional corruption
like in steven spielberg's jaws which
depicts a crooked mayor who cares more
about tourism revenue
than keeping people from becoming shark
bait for christ's sake tomorrow's the
4th of july
and we will be open for business it's
going to be one of the best summers
we've ever had further depictions of the
evil and mighty came in chinatown in
which the sinister billionaire
rejects audiences judgments of him by
claiming that his evil acts were brought
about by his environment
people never have to face the fact that
at the right time
in the right place they're capable of
everything
the suggestion is that circumstances of
power make the villain
rather than any innate nature corrupt
cop films were another popular way of
portraying the power struggles taking
place
serpico based on a true story depicts a
world in which police corruption is an
assumed fact
you're fired without looking you're
firing without a warning without a
[ __ ] brain
in this world bribes and brutality are
the coffee and donuts of police work
so much so that al pacino serpico is
distrusted
because he's not willing to accept
bribes let's face it who can trust the
cop who don't take money
corrupt cops were mainstays on the big
screen popping up in the godfather
white lightning the french connection
and the conversation to name a few
institutions it seems had lost their
presumption of goodwill
and as a result we started seeing
villains who embody the very broken
systems people were angry about take
nurse ratchet from one flew of the
cuckoo's nest who turned a benevolent
profession
into one that turns vivid individuals
into drugged up dependent ghosts of
themselves
you're no crazier than the average
[ __ ] out walking around on the
streets and that's it
in a similarly bleak depiction of
institutionalization escape from
alcatraz renders prisoners sympathetic
heroes struggling against the efforts of
an evil warden
something very similar can be seen in
cool hand luke in
all these cases the person tasked with
imposing law and order or societal norms
is recast as the villain the 1970s
further muddied the waters by blurring
the line between hero and villain
until the distinctions became all but
meaningless these characters are
depicted as conflicted heavily flawed
protagonists with questionable
even hideous morals in martin scorsese's
1976 film taxi driver
travis bickle is one such heroic villain
or villainous hero depending on your
perspective
he swings on the pendulum of violently
bad to violently good-ish
as he goes from plotting to gun down a
presidential candidate to plotting to
rescue a 12 year old prostitute
in the previous year's dog day afternoon
novice crook and
hero slash villain sunny wartzik botches
a bank robbery and spontaneously takes
all the workers hostage however we soon
learned the reason for sonny's dalliance
with crime
he needed the money to help his wife
leon get sexual reassignment surgery
right away sonny wanted to get me money
for the sex change operation but where
is he gonna get it we find out that
sonny is a quality dude who pays his
parents rent and doesn't typically go
around holding up banks
not your villain of the past meanwhile
one particularly popular series star
wars stands
out as markedly simplistic in this era
of more complex villains
it might seem to counter our theory as
it presents a pretty
basic black and white paradigm of good
versus evil even if it goes against the
grain later on with ewoks reminiscent of
the viet cong
the 1980s backpedaled hard on the
anti-villain by reveling in more
cartoonish villains who directly embody
the biggest threats of the time
effectively it ushered back in and us vs
them paradigm
by tapping into the fears surrounding
the war on drugs
unsurprisingly the villains of the time
wanted a piece of that sweet
sweet drug money in films like scarface
to live and die in l.a
beverly hills cop and raw deal this
depiction of evil drug lords could be
seen
as a yin yang response to the less than
savory cops of the 70s films
take tango and cash which depicted two
roguish cops who are treated as
irrepressible protagonists despite
engaging in some of the exact same
violence serpico condemned
however they're portrayed as the best
cops in the city because their
unconventional tactics have cost local
drug lord and rat kissing villain eve's
puree
oodles of money then said kingpin as if
schooled in the bad cop films of the 70s
gets them falsely incriminated for
murder
the film ultimately comes down hard on
the side of cops and a by any means
necessary model of policing i've been a
policeman for 12 years
and i think it's the best organization
in the country at the same time the
decade saw the resurgence of cold war
anxieties as president ronald reagan
increased military spending and ended
arms control
americans rediscovered their fear of
nuclear war
at the same time evil russians had their
moment in the sun with films like rocky
iv
which remained the highest grossing
sports flick until 2009.
it's also been accused of being pure
anti-soviet propaganda because of its
villain
soviet boxer ivan drago who was
decidedly not a charmer
i must thank you the film red heat
really won the villain jackpot in its
depiction of soviet drug lord victor
rostavili who in a trifecta of evil
also murdered the protagonist's partner
but arguably the clearest example of
1980s cold war villains came with 1984's
red dawn which imagined soviet forces
invading america
and worse taking photos in our national
parks the film's director john melius
explicitly saw the film as a warning to
americans to take
seriously the threat of a soviet
invasion via central america
and if this seems like a scare monger
for you consider that melius was the
direct inspiration for this guy
smoking my friend you're entering a
world of pain
despite some return to the other as the
enemy
there are hints of the 70s skepticism
towards institutions in the 1980s
when villains are not pure caricatures
from a nancy reagan fever dream
we see them continue exploiting corrupt
institutions
for personal gain gordon greed is good
gekko for instance
uses the corrupt financial industry to
fulfill his own gold-plated desires
meanwhile die hard's hans gruber emerges
as one of the decade's most enduring
villains
when he and his cronies seize a
high-rise building and take hostages
during a christmas party
he operates under the guise of being a
terrorist exacting revenge on an evil
corporation due to the nakatomi
corporation's
legacy of greed around the globe they
are about to be told a lesson
in the real use of power but
interestingly enough
his moral high ground crumbles when it's
revealed that just like gordon gekko
he's really only after cold hard cash
that's this is all about [ __ ] robbery
put down the gun
[Music]
why'd you have to nuke the whole
building hans well when you steal 600
you can't just disappear when you steal
600 million they will
find you unless they think you're
already dead in the 90s american cinema
swapped out the reds for homegrown
terrorists to fit a decade in which
domestic terrorism
and going postal dominated headlines
fittingly
in cinema it was an era of disgruntled
middle class dudes and bombers next door
a prime time for complex anti-villains
who are fighting small
localized battles by radical means take
the villain from speed howard payne
this former bomb squad officer turned
extortionist turned psychopathic
terrorist
is partially motivated by that sweet 3.7
million dollars
but he also expresses a sense of
superiority
you still don't get it do you jack huh
the beauty of it a bomb is made to
explode
that's its meaning it's purpose that's
bananas but
it's a hint of philosophy a motivation
beyond cold hard cash
howard's more complicated than say
gruber in that he genuinely desires
meaning and purpose it just goes about
getting them in the worst way possible
same goes for kevin spacey's supremely
sadistic john doe in the 1995 film seven
who sees himself as a chosen warrior in
the crusade against everyday sin
we see a deadly sin on every street
corner
in every home and we tolerate it
we tolerate it because it's common it's
it's trivial
we tolerate it morning noon and night
well not anymore
i'm setting the example by the end of
the decade arlington road became the
pinnacle of the domestic terror genre
whose villain mans the girl at the block
party as he carries out plans for his
militant group's latest deadly bombing
i'm a messenger there's millions of us
waiting to take up arms
ready to spread the word he claims to be
pursuing a lofty noble goal
but within his critique of government is
also an indictment of the supposed
niceties of clinton-era prosperity
are you happy in your godless suburban
life
trouble in suburbia also abounded in
american beauty which depicted the enemy
as
lester's neighbor the homophobic nazi
memorabilia hoarding frank fitz who
kills lester after he rebuffs his
romantic advancements
in both cases the villains feel
victimized by the system or circumstance
and seek justice on their own icky terms
sometimes these villains have genuinely
noble causes as they rail against the
systems that have wronged them
take 1995's the rock in which ed
harris's general humble
a disgraced usmc brigadier general
threatens a
nerve gas attack on san francisco 15 vx
gas rockets into the heart of san
francisco you've got 17 hours to deliver
the money
demanding that the families of slain
marines be compensated for their deaths
here we come to an interesting question
of whether noble ends
justify violent needs in this way the
film acts as a prelude to the very
questions being explored by current day
villains
though usually on a much wider scale
movies couldn't not be changed by an
event as pivotal as 911
and the subsequent war on terror with
the 2000s came a new shift in movie
villains
as america confronted an existential
threat to its sense of safety and power
in the world
fittingly the first two installments of
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
captured the popular imagination in this
decade
in 2005's batman begins we see the
dangerous metropolis under attack by an
international terrorist group called the
league of shadows
and its leader raza ghul who in
remarkably on-the-nose metaphor
wants to blow up gotham's tallest
skyscraper arguably the decade's most
salient villain came
of course with heath ledger's portrayal
of the joker in the dark knight the
joker manifests as the spirit of
terrorism the embodiment of anarchy and
chaos of a particularly destructive and
nihilistic nature
as critic douglas kellner writes in his
book cinema wars the only sensible way
to live in this world is without rules
in case the comparison between the joker
and real world terrorism wasn't clear
enough
kellner notes that the film is bursting
with 9 11 iconography
nolan's film also gave us one of two
coin flipping evil-doers with the
character of harvey dent
alias two-face a representation of how a
confrontation with the joker's evils can
corrupt even the noblest person
two-face goes about deciding people's
fates through a plunge into a completely
meaningless existence of pure
contingency and nihilism
meanwhile the coen brothers anton
chaguer from no country for old men
also uses a coin to decide the fate of
his victims he doesn't kill out of greed
self-defense or some kind of practical
goal leading one character to comment
he's a peculiar man he might even say he
has
principles principles that transcend
money or
drugs or anything like that indeed sugur
is quite simply an active nihilist who
believes that if all morality is
contrived
a coin flip is as good a way as any to
decide who lives and dies but
you don't need a coin to affirm the
random or meaningless nature of our
lives or deaths
take martin scorsese's 2006 film the
departed which featured jack nicholson
as chief gangster frank costello
from merciless killing geez she fell
funny to his refusal to subscribe to any
rules
i don't want to be a product of my
environment
i want my environment to be a product
of me frank's action seems shaped by the
belief
that life is meaningless how's your
brother
oh she's on her way out you're act
accordingly
frank who we later find out was an fbi
informant sees life
as one long struggle during which any
actions that sustain you for just
one more day are entirely excusable of
course plenty of other villain
archetypes punctuated the 2000s
but if the 2000s were a time when the
villainous creed was
no creed at all we've come a long way
since then today our villains are the
product of an increasingly divided
america
bracing itself for impact with trust in
government
media and religious faith at all time
lows villains reflect america's innate
skepticism towards systems
any systems all the systems villains
simply embody solutions that are way too
radical and usually
mind-bogglingly violent the polar
opposite of a 1950s villain who
represented an evildoer infiltrating an
inherently good system in hopes of
corrupting it today's villains
increasingly face
objectively evil systems which they want
to change for the better
the only thing that makes these
characters villains rather than
starry-eyed heroes
is their means of carrying out that
change you agreed and the war on drugs
once and for all
my colleagues and i receive full legal
immunity
the classic caveat of hey man you'd be
really cool if you weren't trying to
kill half the world
for instance black panther's killmonger
played by michael b jordan has an
entirely legitimate critique of how the
world treats its black citizens and
wakanda's passivity as they suffer
in fact killmonger would argue that the
real villains of the film are wakandans
who sit on a stockpile of vibranium
while pretending to be a helpless third
world country
where killmonger's perspective gets
debatably tricky is in the means he
wants to ship wakandan weapons all over
the world and instigate a militant
uprising
the world's gonna start over and this
time we're on top
the sun will never set on the wakandan
empire though t'challa defeats him and
stops the scheme
he does go to the u.n to admit wakanda's
real capacities and even establishes a
wakandan outreach center in oakland
suggesting an end to wakanda's
isolationism so killmonger's radicalism
actually brought about a less radical
but positive change in policy
then there's mission impossible six's
new utilitarian villain
august walker john lark who wants to
destroy
a third of the world in the hopes that
the other two thirds would come together
in the wake of the attacks or as he says
there's never been peace
without first the great suffering the
greater the suffering
the greater the peace or infinity wars
thanos who wants to kill half of
everyone to solve resource scarcities
that plague the universe or
incredibles 2's villain screenslaver who
uses hypnotic screens to mind control
her minions
her personal beef with the system that
the endless repackaging of life into
consumable media has made us all
lazy passive observers and that
superheroes are an integral part of the
equation keeping us docile and meek
her plan to change the system mind
control superheroes and ruin their
public approval rating
so people will learn that they have to
protect themselves what all these
villains share is a majorly out there
plan that appeals to our country's
growing fears that the world is screwed
beyond repair
and the only way to fix it is to tear it
all down
in this brave new world of villainy
we're able to empathize with the
villain's critique of the system and
their desire to change it
in this through the looking class
reinterpretation of villainy
the heroes are almost inevitably cast as
slightly flawed protectors of a status
quo that no one's really happy with
in the grand scheme of things
contemporary villains seem to be a weird
mirror image of 50s villains who want to
corrupt good institutions whereas
killmonger types want to affect
good change in corrupt institutions they
just go about it in very bad ways
at the same time our contemporary
villains seem to have merged the
complexity and sometimes
apparent innocence of 90s villains while
broadening the social critiques of the
70s
and standing in opposition to the
nihilism of the 2000s
they do believe that there is a cause
worth fighting for and if they drafted
different blueprints for creating social
change they might just resurface
as complex heroes so what do you guys
think are today's villains more
interesting than past evildoers
and what do you think will come next for
hollywood bad guys let us know in the
comments and as always guys peace